how's it goin right my head is an Eiffel
Tower and welcome back to bully I should
want to change that because I had some
other ones that were that is a pretty
nice one
all right so here we are beautiful okay
we have a lot of quests to do I want to
do something that you bros have been
suggesting me for a long time so I feel
like it's necessary all right we're
gonna go to what the [ __ ] is his name
the hobo and he's gonna teach us like
new tricks and were whatever you
brothers have been told me that I
haven't done it so I don't know I really
give a [ __ ] about new tricks but you
bros wanted me to do it so want to train
again uh we never actually trained but
yeah just what I wanted this was my
favorite okay
he's from Vietnam apparently this hobo
left shift and then hold brain Wayne
there we go whoa it's pretty good
I am alright kid don't think it you
bring me a transistor when you come back
I will not let a near moment
it's called teach lessons or something
alright let's do another one just for
the heck of it I don't know why I had to
go through all this [ __ ] but hey I don't
do you read it I had it right up my back
I hope he doesn't smell you're welcome
alright what we got it on now we were
here literally five seconds ago
whoa I was kicking your ass why would I
be scared
bring me a transistor when you turn
right best as ever say it my work is
done all right so what do we want to go
Bruce um some were saying the red
[ __ ] flag or whatever but I think
that's a sidequest
but if zebras really want may tell do
you want me to go to the red you really
want it take it seriously okay we'll go
to the red flag don't worry about it no
way out of my way [ __ ]
if this is heaven it sucks all right so
where's the red flag anyway all right
[ __ ] foreign [ __ ] I don't want to
wait forever I don't want to wait
forever I want to run into fat people
never twist I don't even remember the
song I was saying hey are you ha ha ha
hey girl what's up girl oh [ __ ] yes yes
look at that
hey Pauly's upset how about a pizza okay
Fred
whoa that police car is sucking me all
right all right
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] they're after me
that's why why do we do let's not get
caught over the fence
whoa holy [ __ ] how did I do that where's
my girlfriend I got kissing in mogera
shed greasers challenge what the five
sucks there's never anything good on TV
you're sad wash do it for you nice place
you guys have found I think I'll take it
what do you want Hopkin I want your
house I want you gone get lost
this is my house and oh oh he wants to
hug all right let's go you move [ __ ]
get out the way get out the way perfect
time to learn them new moose
boom wow that's really hot krispity
krunch [ __ ] Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam huh toes good all right
I'm glad libros told me to go here
because now we have a new save location
there was never any Daft indeed I might
as well save then all right
we're only 20 30 % finish with this game
that's [ __ ] crazy I don't know if
that's true though
um okay which one next bras that one oh
all right if you say so
where's my best part I want like that's
my bike all right we're here we're Roger
we're a okay brother
yeah all right sorry about that I
actually really order to have it I wish
I could pee on him while he's laying
down what is that weird that weird
let's do pretend I'm peeing right now
just good I'll just drop the bomb on him
too that's right
all right so we need to be careful now
brothers there's a lot of nerds nerds
and coming and you know that's dangerous
[ __ ] all right what do we got
come at me bro come at me bro bro bro
come at me bro rah-rah-rah shop dad oh
whoa I [ __ ] penetrated him I didn't
mean to do that that's gross
ow what do you want what you want what
you want what you walk oh sell out to
your little daddy I'm your daddy
that's right that's right all right oh
yeah you want dynomite
BAM I love me some dynamite I got bottle
rockets down what you gonna do you like
shampoo
I love shampoo it's the only thing I can
ride with do it apparently one shot I
love it
one shot a bit one shot dead [ __ ]
but ha ha ha why headshot
one shot one shot BAM
I missed [ __ ] don't you dare duck again
there we go [ __ ] ducks man now I'm
the docket I mean I'm the duck no I'm no
doc I'm no doc what the [ __ ] who said
that BAM come here you little [ __ ] back
oh don't you dare miss my missiles just
cuz I'm missing it
there's nothing you miss it BAM right
say you're sorry
oh yes rockets Oh same come here today
thank you for showing up for no good
reason
fine fine
stop stop stop my agro management
hahahaha oh man I feel nerdy for knowing
that stop inviting me to grab some stay
please
I can't join them okay ah just wait for
them to be although goodbye forever
that's a good one though nerds rule come
on go away thank you
that's like not even a half of them it's
like a million all right there we go
sorry I was not racist I did all right
so this is going pretty well so far
you guys don't even know it whoa wow
that [ __ ] hurts all right so it looks
like filters to fight
it's gonna get rid of these guys Wow
[ __ ] there's a lot of damage alright
let's do like this
ah for [ __ ] sake I'm gonna die now
oh [ __ ] sake yeah I do
Oh for [ __ ] sake nice scar I got to do
that again I got to do that [ __ ] again
did you hear that did you hear that I
got to do it again there we go
bullseye al are they run how does he
even speak while running like that you
kept that same posture but I can't okay
I can do it jesus [ __ ] christ
you gotta be some pep all right what do
you want guys what do you want you just
gonna die anyway you know you're gonna
die
one shot one shot one shot one live one
up and we get it all right okay that's
not the song all right destroy the
observatory doors I can do that I'll
share there's people in check it's gonna
ignore them and keep shooting now there
we go
naylet no respect - hundun no no so much
no but I love nerds Ernest what are you
doing give it up dork you work for me
now you're pathetic
you've defeated my weakest compadres
you've just met you're mad I want us to
be friends I need your help
I've had friends like you that's kind to
treat you like dog muck on their eyes
I'm really good bug come on my brains
against your brawn welcome to hell Jimmy
Hopkins uh okay you think it's funny now
I never thought it was funny your bum
then you'll be sorry this is just a
prototype dude we'll all help one we'll
all have one I want one now
okay I need to shoot where those arrows
are pointing I know what it does though
but hey it says there's something oh wow
all of them that doesn't do anything
ah okay yeah oh he's gonna die oh he ran
in the air what the [ __ ] Jimmy is this
for you wait wait isn't that a movie
it's not the omen this is for you
wait stop throwing mine sit stairs and
dangerous day you'll regret it yes sir
Hey okay I heard you the first time you
don't have to say two times in a row
there we go
that's how I am it's gunman's like a
fish
maybe now you listen to me oh oh I want
that thank you
just like everyone else picking on the
little man I'm not like everyone else
Oh honestly yay I'm good now listen we
both want the same thing to teach those
jocks Alexis from now on we're buddies
you have a funny way of showing
friendship we're friends we work
together like nice way to force a
friendship we're [ __ ] friends no
respect [ __ ] I'm sorry okay I
know you're jealous of my dancing and
that's okay that's totally fine do you
want to be jelly
i-i'll make you some which flavor would
you like
alright we can get this our house now I
think the shortcut here I have a potato
gun now that's pretty badass let's try
it out on some jocks hello oh hello
hello
I just defend the Nerds family potatoes
I'm the potato King oh it doesn't do a
lot a lot of damage I'm sorry sorry I'll
do it
oh did you want something I beat up
everyone instead oh sorry about that
sorry about that
I don't know I don't know what I'm going
I know nobody's goin I'm shocked ah
blows off lighter brighter we're that
way there I went what is this what's
going on here hey boy Fred speak I'm
sorry
hey I'm sorry I try to throw you the
fist goddamned doggies where the [ __ ] am
I all right that's the quest over here
if I could go here why the hell am I
going I don't know buddy
no one all right boo potato gun can of
spuds what the [ __ ] is spot get over
that Jimmy do nice dance brother whoa I
wish I could dance like that that was
indeed asterick on a yard big hello are
you in rich or just naturally dumped
that was racist Jimmy that was racist
all right what do we got here fun house
fun
I think this quest will be fun Russ what
do you think oh hey Jimmy hey Pete yo
Jimmy I'm over here
poor Jimmy Whoopie buddy uh no I ain't
gonna do are you talking about don't get
can you please talk normally look is my
normal style of rapping bro yeah oh
that's so awesome
all right salutations sir James
uh-huh seems my clever brethren have
taken control of the funhouse at the
carnival
well done all that education and now you
run a funhouse genius you simple-minded
noble foot soldier the football team is
going to be there this afternoon what
you got too close to that face okay
explain
to be on our way over there's not much
to explain just access the control rooms
through the maintenance doors then do
your thing
cool cool moonwalk oh oh oh that guy's
swagger
LG's like the best character of this
game for sure all right so we're gonna
phone the house in the carnival I've
been told that it's pretty [ __ ]
awesome to go there so yeah looking for
it only over LG sorry about that
then work all the over tiny black guy
that was racist didn't work all right
all the AO liberation girl I worked I
was thought that was good
almost there now bras hanging hang tight
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
everything good such awesome speed all
right
oh look it's a tiny woman hello how are
ya I should do him
alright then let's go to the funhouse
Bros that's where the magic happens
that's where the fun Algie how the hell
did you get here so quickly
here let's funhouse oh is it whoa what
the [ __ ]
alright I looking forward to this [ __ ]
meet up with the Nerds whoa
I hate the fun hours at carnivals it
freaked me out
let's go it up I'm trippin balls uh I
have so many years ahead
where the [ __ ] did they come from I said
I gotta help them heal that's not no let
release him there we go
there we go that's one down and then
another one I'm so glad you've got here
Jimmy the docks taking over you gotta
get us out of here
the jocks have taken out lead the Nerds
out of the funhouse oh jeez all right
follow me that's finally we can't go
there nerds um but we can go here oh
[ __ ] I push this book all right what is
this gonna do how the ladder comes down
that's a bit tricky on its lay I was
like at the [ __ ] are the Nerds you've
been following me
what's it [ __ ] where am I uh-oh what is
out stand out it's dangerous
[ __ ] my doors oh stop stop her at oh
if I die from this I'm gonna die there
we go
activate the graveyard controls alright
so I get to kill the jock style that it
I have decided to make you sucker I am
deciding to kill you right in the face
what I'm gonna smack the faces slappa
you [ __ ] murder people hear about me
smartass ah sly such coach but find a
way out of the graveyard we gotta go
back
search the maze for the Nerds oh [ __ ]
not a maze I got a cliche come on
thanks to me now find fatting well nice
going Jimmy get that [ __ ] door Oh bad
you can't click on it
what are you doing Jimmy stop vibrating
you're not a vibrator Jimmy Jimmy took
too many drugs I love the way your dad
can you get get away so I can click on
this like there we go no eggs oh it's so
creepy those eyes are looking look at
that arm it's like holding [ __ ] Russ as
something happened here my my webcam
just would stop working so it's just
these last couple seconds of this quest
it's so funny look at the mirror like a
Southside
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha that's hilarious Oh
what about this one on the same ha ha
onam a fat soprano frankly that's your
new nickname what we got here what do we
got there we go oh hello I didn't know
there was Nadia's don't be shy nerds
don't be shy just picture there naked
that's what I do with my bras what
doesn't make sense I am on air and we
escaped thank you so much you're welcome
no respect [ __ ] all right
brother
that's all the time I had for today but
like a favorite if you enjoyed subscribe
come over today and I'll see you next
episode
ai ai ai ai ai ai
there we go if it doesn't opened hand
but that [ __ ] Jesus Christ man